hi in this video we're going to talk
about translation in prokaryotes and
this is going to be an overview based on
this video we're going to talk about all
the processes of translation in
prokaryotes in a lot more details in the
subsequent videos now let's begin in
case of prokaryotes the translation
begins at a particular sequence near the
shine-dalgarno sequence which is known
as the start codon which is generally a
ug shine-dalgarno sequence is an
important sequence near the start codon
which ensures the ribosome binding the
proper site and followed by ribosome
binding ribosome translocates along the
mRNA and while it translocates along the
mRNA it keep on forming a necklace of
peptides forming the polypeptide and
that's how the protein is synthesized so
this is the overall framework of
prokaryotic translation translation is
bit different in prokaryote because
before even the mRNA is fully
synthesized ribosomes can be attached to
the mRNA and transcribing the peptide
the scenario is very different in the
eukaryote where the mRNA has to be
transported out of the nucleus first in
order to perform a round of translation
now let's talk about the zeroeth step of
the translation before even translation
can start the raw materials need to be
charged the raw materials for
translation is the amino acids the amino
acids are the building block of any
proteins so the amino acids need to be
loaded onto the tRNA such that they
could be easily taken to the ribosome
and ribosome works like a necklace
making machine where it just take all
these beads and make a necklace out of
it
so aminoacyl-trna synthetase is an
enzyme that utilize ATP to attach the
amino acid at the end of the
tRNA now the tRNAs 3-prime end there is
a CCA motive and at the last adenine has
a hydroxyl group which works like a
nuclear field and it attacks the ATP
bound peptide now at that particular
situation what happens there is a
rearrangement taking place and
ultimately the amino acid is now bind
with bound with three prime end of the
tRNA now this tRNA is called as charged
with a particular amino acid so this is
the zeroth step of translation that
means the charging of the amino acid and
the key role is played by aminoacyl-trna
synthesis in an atp-dependent fashion
now the overall translation process is
divided into three phases initiation
elongation and termination let's look at
initiation first so in the process of
initiation the key events are assembly
of the small and large subunit of the
ribosome
so the process starts at the start codon
which is Aug but near that there is a
sequence which is a consensus sequence
known as shine-dalgarno sequence the
shine-dalgarno sequence is pretty much
complementary to the 16s rRNA which is a
component of the small subunit of
ribosome ribosome has three sites for
processing the trna which is bringing
other amino acids esight p site and the
a site we would look at all the
functions of these sites in lot more
details as we proceed now first of all
the process of initiation begins when F
mid tRNA is if met tRNA is binding to
the Aug codon but wait a minute let's
look at this process slowly and a little
bit a little bit more details the whole
process of initiation is augmented by
several initiation factor
several initiation factors such as if1
and I have three bind to the small
subunit of the ribosome and escorts it
to the place near the shine-dalgarno
sequence now the 16s rRNA makes
non-covalent interaction with the
shine-dalgarno sequence ensuring that
the small subunit of the ribosome is now
at a proximity of the AUG or the start
codon site second step is a f2 which is
work which is working in a GTP dependent
manner escorting the F mid trna to the
initiator site and the F mate trna can
form interactions with the start codon
Aug after all of these things the if2
hydrolyzes its GTP and the GTP
hydrolysis is triggered by the Assembly
of the large subunit because one part of
this large subunit of the ribosome
actually helps in gtp hydrolysis and
this ends the initiation process let's
move on to look at the elongation
process so after the ribosomal big
subunit is attached all the initiation
factors falls off next we move to
elongation and try to understand the
events that takes place in the
elongation elongation starts with
charging the amino acids onto the tRNAs
three prime end so many of these amino
acids are synthesized in the cytoplasm
in case of bacteria it's only one places
but the amino acid abundance ensures the
rate of translation so aminoacyl-trna
how fast it is working it also depends
upon the abundance of amino acid present
in the media and present inside the
cytoplasm so after charging what happens
these amino acid these amino acid bound
tRNAs are actually escorted to the a
side of the ribosomes by elongation
factor known as elongation factor
you elongation factor pu is an
interesting elongation factor so it can
only work or only bind to the tRNA at
the three prime end when it is bound to
gtp and it binds in a specific fashion
as if it masks the amino acid from the
interaction with another amino acid in
the ribosome but the question is who
actually triggers the GTP hydrolysis
because without GTP hydrolysis the amino
acid is not going to be unmasked and up
new peptide bond cannot be formed
so when ef-tu has scored this particular
tRNA to the a site of the ribosome then
what happens there is a GTP hydrolysis
event triggered by one portion of the
ribosome known as factor binding center
the same portion actually lead to
hydrolysis of the GTP of elongation
factor of initiation factor two so this
fact this particular region is known as
factor binding center which hydrolyzes
GTP and freez of ef-tu and that starts
the process of peptide bond formation
otherwise known as peptidyl transferase
activity of the large subunit but what
if an incorporate the incorrect amino
acid is incorporated in the ribosomes a
site the question we should ask is like
how does proofreading works in case of
translation and what is the error rate
it turns out the innernette
of translation is quite high it's 10 to
the power minus 3 to 10 to the power
minus 4 which was quite a higher than
compared to replication because for
replication the error rate is 10 to the
power minus 9 right now here is a trick
so there are a few mechanisms which
ensures that the pairing or the pairing
between incoming aminoacyl-trna and the
codon takes place properly so first of
all there are
two portions of the 16s rRNA having
double adenine at that just inside which
interacts with the codon and the
anticodon loop of the incoming trna if
the interaction is proper then only
elongation can take place if them in the
incorporation is improper the elongation
cannot take place and the peptidyl
transferase activity one would be
hampered second ef-tu
is sitting on the tRNA in a fashion that
it was it is very difficult for the tRNA
to actually initiate the process of
peptidyl transferase next if you need to
be dissociated from the particular
complex such that the elongation can
take place further but ef-tu is only
hydrolyzed when it is properly oriented
in the a site this process is known as
accomodation and all this thing happens
when there is a proper codon anticodon
pairing and if the pairing is not good
these processes as a hampered as a
result elongation is paused but let's
say elongation is proper so let's look
at the peptidyl transferase activity and
who is responsible for this peptidyl
transferase activity so let's look at or
zoom into the a site and the P site of
the ribosome in the a site of the
ribosome there is the incoming amino
acid acyl tRNA and the P site has the
amino acyl tRNA which was bound
previously now what would happen is the
first step where the nuclear fields of
nh-2 group of one amino acid would hit
the carbon center of another amino acid
sitting in the P site forming a peptide
bond between these two and as a result
there would be
peptide bond present in the p-side the
next round would again begin when
another charge tRNA is incoming at the
ASI now the particular tRNA which was
present in the p-side moves to the east
side and it is released or injected a
new tRNA charged with amino acid is
incoming at the ASI which is ready to
form another round of peptide bond so
this whole peptidyl transferase activity
is intrinsic property of the ribosomal
large subunit and it turns out the
peptidyl transferase activity is
actually due to the an actual it is
present in the ribonucleoprotein or the
RNA part because if you get rid of the
proteins in the large subunit still the
peptidyl transferase activity remains so
it's pretty wonderful to understand how
peptidyl transferase activity works
now as the ribosome proceeds in the
right hand side and which is triggered
by elongation factor g which helps the
ribosome to be translocated three cool
amid three particular nucleotides or a
codon towards the right side and this
EMG works in a gtp dependent manner
elongation factor G walks in and gtp
dependent manner so when it's moving to
the right hand side the peptide chain is
elongating and make getting bigger and
eventually the ribosome while moving
down the mRNA it would encounter a
particular region which would lead to
termination termination takes place when
ribosome reached the position of a stop
codon in this case you a a ribosomal a
site is present at UAA which is the stop
codon site at this particular point of
time for a stop codon there is no
aminoacyl-trna so nothing can come in
here
instead a release factor binds to this
stop codon release factor has a ggq
motive which also worked like a cutter
people hypothesize that this ggq motive
helped to dissociate the growing peptide
chain from the ribosome and allowing
dissociation of the whole complex and
that is how the peptide which is formed
and which is composed of several amino
acid is released into the cytoplasm for
further processing and that's how the
process of transcription the translation
is finished so I hope this video was
informative and helpful for you guys if
you liked this video give it a big
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you